today the Matt wall Show Jon Stewart
allegedly delivers the definitive
Smackdown to conservative bigots who
believe that men are men and women are
women today we'll take a look at the
viral clip from this much celebrated
segment and show just how easily and
thoroughly it can all be debunked also
we achieve a major victory as Vanderbilt
announces that it will be pausing all
gender transition procedures on minors
well a lot to say about that and the by
Administration decides it must remind
parents across the country that your
sons and your family names can be ended
anytime they feel like and in our daily
cancellation a Christian Pastor explains
his problem with what is a woman namely
that I'm in it all of that and more
today on the Matt Walsh show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
October is cyber security awareness
month and right now is the perfect time
to ensure you're doing everything you
can to stay safer online be cybersmart
by taking these basic steps to help keep
you and your family protected from
identity theft scams and other online
dangers use strong passwords set up your
multi-factor authentication on
authentication on your accounts and
regularly update the software on your
devices you know it's important to
understand how cyber crime and identity
theft are affecting our lives every day
we put our information at risk on the
internet in an instant a cyber criminal
could harm what's yours your finances
your credit everything
good thing there's LifeLock LifeLock
helps detect a wide range of identity
threats like your social security number
for sale on the dark web if they detect
your information
um they'll send you an alert nobody can
prevent
all identities after monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can keep what's yours with Lifelock
Identity Theft Protection right now uh
you can join and save up 25 off your
first year at lifelock.com Walsh that's
lifelock.com Welsh for 25 off
well last week was you might say
eventful it began with three major
medical organizations calling for the
prosecution of high profile social media
personalities who have been reporting on
and criticizing so-called gender
affirming care
um having extremely well-funded and
Powerful medical associations not so
subtly single me out and call for my
arrest would have been enough activity
for one week as far as I'm concerned but
very next day Media Matters launched
their most extensive hit piece against
me Edna transparent attempt to derail
our campaign against gender ideology and
while this is all going on uh we were
also in the first week of our what is a
woman College Tour where throngs of
protesters complain that my presence was
destabilizing their existence and
responded by defiantly singing Bohemian
Rhapsody in a vocal performance that
resembled the sound of seven thousand
chickens choking to death all at once
and then came the big win on Friday uh
the Capstone to all these events at the
end of a week where I think our enemies
thought that they landed a knockout blow
it was announced by Vanderbilt in a
letter to State lawmakers that they
would be pausing all gender transition
procedures on minors so they caved they
surrendered for perhaps
the first time in recent memory anyway a
left-wing Institution
caved to pressure from the right
very rarely does that happen but we beat
them battle is not close to over the
Fight Continues of course as we now move
on to to make gender transitions on
minors illegal across the entire State
and then we move across the entire
country but this was a major victory and
I think perhaps
in some ways unprecedented
and we'll have much more to say about it
in a few minutes but the week was not
over with the Vanderbilt news
that night
Jon Stewart opened the second season of
his Apple TV show Even though nobody
watched the first season he got the
second season anyway a little bit more
of that to left-wing privilege that he's
benefiting from
um most people didn't even know that the
first season happened but it did did
season two episode one comes along and
focuses on the topic of gender
um it is in effect Jon Stewart's
response to our documentary what is a
woman and even features a brief clip of
the film the left has hailed this
episode as the ultimate takedown of the
conservative conspiracy theory that
women don't have penises this is the it
just demolishes all of us we're told
so to begin the show today we're going
to go through
what are being celebrated as the most
compelling and persuasive moments from
this episode
and we will show that Jon Stewart is a
shallow spineless left-wing hack who has
long had the reputation as a free
thinker and a sort of bold comedic mind
even though he is always simply adopted
the mainstream corporate position on
literally every topic
and that's what he's done now on gender
so we start with a clip shared by the
show's Twitter account and the the
caption of this clip on their Twitter
account was what is a woman it's a
question that suddenly is everywhere and
it turns out the answer is complicated
John breaks down the gender binary and
gender Spectrum in this week's episode
we are in a new dawn of gender and sex
complexity where those who don't fit
into a simple binary are meant to be
seen with Humanity
it wasn't always like this people as
recently as let's say the 1990s early
2000s people were making reductive jokes
about the subject
what can I say the joke rhymed
it would be sad to see Jon Stewart
apologizing for his past jokes
disavowing his previous belief that men
can't have babies and groveling for
acceptance from a bunch of purple-haired
22 year olds but you must realize that
Jon Stewart has always been a pathetic
fraud this is fully in keeping with his
brand it's it's still a sickening
stomach churning display of
self-debasement as revolting and
perverse as watching someone eat
themselves on camera but it's exactly
what you ought to expect from a lifelong
shill let's continue
any moment of progressive visibility
will be met with a vicious backlash
there are two genders there are two
genders and everyone knows it eight but
two genders
that last guy sounded like it's an
emergency and we're running out of
genders everyone one they're able to
genders
so here you see uh the attempt to make a
completely self-evident and obvious
statement seem absurd the audience with
the enhancement of a laugh track giggles
at the statement that there are only two
genders like this is the move if you
just laugh at something then that
automatically makes it laughable
expecting us to believe that the claim
is funny just because they're laughing
at it
but they can't make this objectively
correct statement funny by laughing
about it any more than they can make a
statement like the world is round or Jon
Stewart is a gutless smirking slug funny
by laughing about it these are all just
simply objective self-evident
observations about the physical world
it's really not funny at all but let's
uh continue along
the point is clear
the human race is defined by a simple
binary a black and white understanding
there are men and there are women and
never the twain shall meet Trump is an
alpha male well okay yes there are
obviously men who are more man than
other men but that's an aberration Vader
gamma okay there's an entire Greek Alpha
but a Continuum of masculinity but that
doesn't mean [ __ ] Pajama Boy of soy boy
girlyman
I hope the children are out of the room
clearly masculinity appears to be on a
dimmer not an on off switch but ladies
are different I was a big tomboy these
purple-haired angry freaks rabid
feminist cat lady hi Roman bimbos pretty
girly girl
my God
what a cruise line Buffet of the
gradients in American gender expression
turns out there's a lot of non-binary
happening between the binaries
this is this is Johnson by the way just
he this is this he goes back to the
Daily Show just play a clip of someone
saying something normal and then mug for
the camera like it's you know the
episode an episode of The Office just
someone says something normal and you
look at the camera like
and then that's that's the joke it's
like automatically that thing is now
funny but these are all just
descriptions of personality traits and
most of them are labels used to describe
the same sorts of people so
how does this at all even slightly call
into question the existence of the man
woman binary nobody ever said John that
every man is exactly the same as every
other man or that every woman is the
same as every other woman squares can
also come in many different shapes and
colors and rather many different sizes
and colors not shapes that's the point a
square is still a square so you can
color a different color you can have a
big square a little square there are
lots of different ways you can describe
squares depending on how you decorate
them but a square is still Square you
can do a lot of interesting things with
a square you can't make it a circle is
the point
so is that really the best that Stuart
can do just like pointing out that there
are different personality traits
different ways that you can describe uh
individual men different insults you can
use against individual women that's what
is that it is that all you have
is that what the left considers some
kind of definitive Smackdown of the
gender binary surely he must have more
in his Arsenal he doesn't of course but
we'll keep watching anyway
that hasn't stopped the traditionalists
from deploying their newest weapon in
the culture war arsenal the obvious
gotcha question the real basic question
what is a woman can you provide a
definition for the word woman for all of
recorded history people have known what
a woman is yes
all of recorded history
it was simple until like a year ago the
answer to what is a woman has always
been the same it's a a woman is a
deformity that occurred in the ordinary
course of nature
sorry that's that's Aristotle I
apologize that's I'm sorry that's not
what I meant I meant a woman is a person
who has no legal existence once married
that's I'm sorry that's that's early
American coverture law that's that's not
right no the throughout history it's not
a gotcha question a woman is 30 shekels
that's I'm sorry
I'm sorry that's Leviticus
yes John those are different things that
different people and institutions have
said about women over the course of
history but what is your point Aristotle
and the author of Leviticus and everyone
else that you might name from ancient
history all agreed on what a woman is
fundamentally and physically they all
agreed that a woman can be defined
because if they didn't then they
couldn't have said anything about women
in the first place Stacy John that's
what you're not feared not understanding
it you can't even talk about them you
can't say anything about them at all
unless there's some shared understanding
of what this entity is
what you're proving is that over history
people have had different ideas about
the legal standing of women about their
place in society and so on and so on but
you haven't proved that there was ever
at any time ever in history ever until
just now even the slightest disagreement
on the definition of the word
no indeed you've proven the opposite if
anything
I mean there are people who would say
different things about Jon Stewart some
people would say he's a comedic genius
on the other hand people with
functioning brains say that he's a bland
boring chump desperate for approval
these are all adjectives some of them
more accurate than others they don't
make Jon Stewart into some kind of
abstract undefinable entity whose very
objective existence is now Up For Debate
but Stuart isn't done here he also
interviews Leslie Rutledge who's the
Arkansas attorney general and the Great
American who's helped to spearhead the
efforts in her state to make it illegal
to sexually mutilate children
yet not every Great American is
necessarily equipped to successfully
respond to a partisan hack like Stewart
while the cameras are rolling okay not
everyone is is going to be good in that
context and unfortunately it doesn't
seem like Rutledge really is which is
exactly why she was chosen for this
segment but let's watch a little bit of
this
why would the state of Arkansas step in
to override
parents
Physicians
psychiatrists
endocrinologists who have developed
guidelines why would you override those
guidelines
well I think it's important that all of
those Physicians all of those experts
for every single one of them there's an
expert that says we don't need to allow
children to be able to take those
medications that there are many
incidences where but you know that's not
true you know it's not for everyone
there's one there's these are the
established well I don't know that
that's not true I don't know that then
why would you why would you pass a law
then if you don't if you don't know that
that's true wouldn't you well I know
that there are doctors and that we had
plenty of people come and testify before
our legislature who said that uh you
know we have 98 of the young people who
have gender dysphoria that they are able
to move past that and once they have the
the help that they need no longer suffer
from gender dysphoria 98 without that
medical treatment that's an incredibly
made up figure
that's that doesn't comport with any of
the
studies or documentation that exists
from these medical organizations what
what Medical Association are you talking
about of these doctors well we have all
of that in our uh legislative history
and we'll be glad to provide that to you
okay Jon Stewart was of course extremely
careful about which conservative he
invited to speak to him about this issue
um I don't think I'm inflating myself in
any respect by saying that I am
primarily the one who's brought the what
is a woman question to the Forefront and
yet Stewart didn't reach out to me for
an interview if he had I would have
eagerly accepted and here's how I would
have responded instead of making the
mistake of getting into a credentialism
contest as Rutledge does here takes the
bait once you do that it's over okay
that's that's all this conversation is
now
I would have said something like this
John you're coming out of the gate with
appeals to Authority because you don't
have any thoughts of your own that's the
first problem
there was a time when a similar appeal
to Authority could have been used to
prove that the Earth is the center of
the universe or that bloodletting is the
cure for every known disease okay there
was a time when every medical expert in
the world would have told you that if
you want to cure any disease cut
yourself open and Bleed It Out
in this case your brainless appeals to
Authority are even more asinine because
the authorities you mention all have an
obvious Financial stake in the very
medical practices you're seeking to
justify so what you're telling me is
that people who make millions of dollars
mutilating kids all say it's a good idea
to mutilate kids wow breaking news the
tobacco industry also has funded studies
showing that smoking isn't so bad for
you will you be citing those on your
next show John
but this is all beside the point
the burden of proof is not on me to
explain to you why we shouldn't castrate
and sterilize children you guys are the
ones coming along out of nowhere
demanding that we start engaging in
those kinds of horrific practices so you
tell me what your evidence is what
studies are you talking about tell me
John which credible long-term studies
prove that it's a good idea to castrate
a mutilated kids which ones
which ones here I'll help you there are
none they don't exist
these medical institutions don't have
studies to support their practices our
kids are the study this current
generation is the guinea pig the lab
rats
that's the part you're leaving out you
sycophantic gas bag
now I'd like to tell you that this
conversation progresses from here but it
really doesn't Stewart spends the entire
interview obsessing over the guidelines
of medical organizations that's the only
thing they talk about so well this
organization said that we should do it
so we should
that's literally all he has that's it
this whole case comes down to
um
these people said we should castrate
kids
which people uh well the people who make
billions of dollars doing it
oh great good to know
he also lies of course and misrepresents
the data let's check that out
I've got some bad news for you
parents with children who have gender
dysphoria have lost children
to suicide and depression and they
absolutely
and so these mainstream medical
organizations have developed guidelines
through peer-reviewed data and studies
and through those guidelines they've
improved mental health outcomes
what date is that John what are you
talking about you're saying that there
is data showing that a child's long-term
mental health is improved by castrating
and sterilizing and mutilating him
which data exactly is that where is that
data can you cite it
say Leslie right Ledger fortunately
never flips it around on him he's very
lucky that she never thinks to say what
what are you talking about what do you
can you show me
what are you talking about can you
provide an example can you say anything
about it other than insisting that it
exists
no you can't because it doesn't exist it
never has existed and it never will
you're lying
unfortunately for you your guest didn't
call you out on that
but I will and I do it to your face if
you had the courage to sit down with
someone who won't be so easily
railroaded
but in some ways I'm grateful for the
Jon Stewart episode he's you know he's
grateful for it because it's the first
time anyone has paid attention to him in
like eight years I'm grateful because
it's being heralded as the the best
defense of gender ideology ever put to
film
and yet it's laughably weak and can be
dismantled with almost no effort at all
and that really tells you everything you
need to know
about gender ideology
and about Jon Stewart
now let's get to our five headlines
all right I would be remiss if I didn't
uh just start off on our five headlines
with the biggest headline of the day
which is that it's Columbus Day and
happy Columbus Day to everybody who is
uh watching and who celebrates and
hopefully that is everyone who
celebrates Columbus Day because despite
what you have heard and we continue to
hear every single year on this day that
oh we're not going to celebrate Columbus
ever accelerating digits people's day
despite anything that you've heard
Columbus was
uh one of the most consequential figures
in all of history especially in all of
Western history
and
all of our lives would be dramatically
different
for the worse if Columbus never in fact
we might not even exist a lot of us
this is one of those one of those things
like one of those people you go back in
time and remove him from the equation
you've just Rewritten everything that
happens after it
so who knows what would happen from
there
um but
a great man who accomplished
extraordinary Feats of of courage and
and and and uh who's
contributions to history have stood the
test of time
and yet of course as with so many other
historical figures his statues are being
torn down his monuments are being
defaced his name's being taken off of
buildings and off of holidays and he's
being um
posthumously his whole life is being
posthumously relitigated relitigated and
he's being convicted of all these crimes
long after he's dead and all of this is
happening on the part of people
who are pathetic
and who have had no impact on history
and won't I mean whose lives will be
instantly forgotten the moment that they
die
and yet they feel like they're in a
place to cast judgment on one of the
most significant men of history he's one
of the most significant men you're
nothing like you're you are in no one
you're not contributing anything to the
world at all he helped to reshape it
and so that should be reason enough to
humble yourself
and honor the greater people who came
before you and and and who established
this civilization that you live in and
that you are happy to live in despite
what you may claim
you live in modern Western society and
you are happy that you do because if you
weren't you'd go somewhere else but you
don't you stay here you stay here and
you complain about and whine about all
of the better people who came before you
and gave you all of the things that you
take for granted today
that makes you a whiny insignificant
brat
but for everybody else happy Columbus
Day all right now uh for more on the
story mentioned at the top of the show
the Vanderbilt pediatric gender Clinic
has agreed to pause all gender
transition surgeries on minors according
to a letter from the clinic to a
Tennessee lawmaker obtained by the daily
wire Vanderbilt also told the lawmakers
that would protect conscientious
objectors who worked at the facility and
don't want to take part in the
controversial treatments
they said we are pausing gender
affirmation surgeries on patients under
18 while we complete this review which
may take several months
the clinic says they've done about five
such gender affirming surgical
procedures per year
which I don't believe
but this is what they're claiming since
they opened in 2018 the letter addressed
to I don't believe because I think it's
much uh more than that to be clear the
latter addressed to Republicans state
representative Jason Zachary
was written by C Wright Pinson the
deputy CEO and chief Health System
officer at Vanderbilt University Medical
Center Pinson said that parental consent
had been given in each case for the
surgery and that no General procedures
had been done uh but they're going to
stop doing that but here's the best part
okay well the best part is that they're
pausing the procedures and that is and
that is going to really in real time
save kids
[Music]
at least buy them some time
from you know being mutilated in this
way so that's the best part this part's
also good
continuing with the article says Pinson
also said that the clinic com complied
with existing Tennessee law and would
comply with any potential legislation
that the legislature may pass
he wrote In addition we understand this
issue it's likely to be taken up by the
general assembly in its next legislative
session as always we will assure that
view vumc's programs comply with any new
requirement which may be established as
part of Tennessee law
um so they're waving the white flag on
the legislative fight before it even
really begins now you might say well all
they're doing is saying they're going to
comply with the law what else are they
going to say they're not going to
announce ahead of time that they're not
going to comply with the law
well in fact they could announce that
it's bomb I mean they could come out and
say well this is we're putting our foot
down we're not going to go along with
this
um but they also one way or another they
didn't need to make a point in the
letter of saying oh yeah we heard about
the fact that you're going to try to
make this illegal and we'll go along
with it
I I certainly read that I think within
reason as uh waving the white flag and
saying they're they're not going to
fight it
they are surrendering
so again this represents an occasion one
of the very few occasions where a
left-wing institution caves to pressure
from the right
I can't remember the last time that's
happened
okay it almost always happens the other
way institutions cave to pressure from
the left
and especially conservative institutions
what few exist
um generally also gave us to push press
from the left
but it's not an accident that had
happened
okay we didn't we didn't just like Get
Lucky in this case
we engineered this
we made it happen it's all strategic
how do we do it well utilizing a
multi-prong approach
first was the public pressure
okay and that and that and that's uh
involves alerting the public making them
aware and also you know there are many
different ways to make people aware that
something's happening you can just say
oh this is happening
um but to really capture people you need
to sort of tell the story of what you
want them to know in a way that
resonates and makes sense
that's another thing that I think
oftentimes the right we fail in that
regard
we kind of like to just take a
bulletproof Point approach here's what
happened here's what's happening boom
boom boom
doesn't resonate people just it doesn't
it doesn't capture people
so the first thing is to make is to make
people aware to capture them
and then we work with lawmakers to
generate political pressure and um and
these two together create Financial
pressure you got public pressure
political pressure now you also have
Financial pressure because donors and
supporters of Vanderbilt threatening to
pull their funds and all the rest of it
so now now you've got public political
Financial
attacked from all angles
back them into a corner you don't wait
for them to do the right thing you don't
just hope that they'll have a change of
heart you force them
leave them no option
and that's what happened here
now I think it's important to celebrate
a victory when it happens and I do
believe again this is a significant
Victory it's not over though
um
what we can't do the mistake we can't
make is to say well uh well we won that
let's just move on to the next thing
no because it's still legal to do in
Tennessee there are still other now this
might be the big sort of gender clinic
in Tennessee but there are other medical
clinics that perform these kinds of
procedures there's there are plastic
surgeons that perform double
mastectomies on minors even even ones in
Nashville who aren't directly connected
with uh with Vanderbilt so the fight
certainly continues and which is why
it's all the more important now
um if you are able to come out on
October 21st
here in Nashville 4 P.M we're going to
have our rally we're still having our
rally even more important than ever to
show up and uh speak out against us we
hope we hope to see you there all right
look at this tweet from The Selective
Service this is uh
I don't even know exactly how to process
this but this is real okay
this is from the government
very real it says
parents if your son is an only son and
the last male in your family to carry
the family name
he is still required to register with
SSS
learn more about who needs to register
at sss.gov
what
here's the translation parents we may
kill your son and end your bloodline and
your family name for the sake of
Defending some irrelevant pile of sand
and some godforsaken corner of the globe
that holds no worth to you or your
family whatsoever but uh that's just
what we're gonna do
now it's hard to understand why they
would even say something like this now
yeah it's true that there is no
provision in the law that says that you
don't have to register your son if he's
the if he's the last male in your family
that's so yes
technically accurate but
why would you come out and say that like
what why
um and it seems confusing until you
remember back to what we talked about a
couple of weeks ago when lizzo was uh
playing the flute
and amazingly these two things are
pretty unrelated and they are except in
this one area where this is about
demoralization
that's the only way to understand this
thing from the from Selective Service
why else would they put that out there
just hey just let you guys know just
reminding you that we can take your sons
and kill them and erase your family name
and bloodline from history why else
would you come out and say it other than
to demoralize people
it's like the only reason you would ever
say that
it's to demoralize people and to sort of
let you know let us know where we fall
in the hierarchy that we are the peons
and that uh they can come along at any
time and take our children and have them
killed off and and you know in some war
that if it's anything like uh the the
military engagements that we've had in
recent history it'll be something that
is completely irrelevant to to our
national interests
speaking of the draft this is from
post-millennial this is also from today
it says the bind administration's
requirements for who must register for
Selective Service in the event that
there's a draft
includes those persons that identify as
transgender but are born male
almost all male U.S citizens and male
immigrants who are 18 through 25 are
required to register with Selective
Service and that includes males who
identify as transgender
guidance on requirements for The
Selective Service System say U.S
citizens are immigrants who are born
male and change their gender to female
are still required to register
individuals who are born female and
change their gender to male are not
required to register
as soon as Biden took office he enacted
an executive order one of many that said
those who identify as transgender should
be treated by the military according to
their gender identity and not according
to their biological sex
okay
so this is very interesting
now we we know that there's this effort
um to and there's been a push in recent
years to make women eligible for the
draft
and I know there have even been some
people on the right who've supported
this not because they supported in
principle because but because they see
it as kind of a
they see it as an Fu to the feminists
and they say oh so you want to be
treated like a man well now you're going
to be drafted
now I I can't get behind that because
it's not you know what what feminists
are you thinking you're flipping a
finger to here you see you have in your
mind like feminist College professors
and gender studies professors they're
not the ones who are going to get
drafted okay it's like my daughter gets
drafted and yours
so you you line up behind this because
you think that it proves some point to
the feminist they're not the ones that
are going to suffer and die it'll be
your your own daughters
I don't want my my daughters have
nothing to do with this yes it's true
that our culture has bought into this
feminist lie of this you know leftist
lie in general that men and women are
the same my daughter's have nothing to
do with that it's not their fault why
should they have to pay the price for
that
so I don't the idea of drafting women I
think is uh
horrific
and immoral in the extreme
and a and a sign of a civilization
that's that's simply given up
you know when you get to the point where
you're sending your you are conscripting
your daughters to go die on the
battlefield that is a civilization that
has surrendered that has given up
completely
um
so
we don't know if that will ultimately go
through or not that women are getting
going to get drafted
but until that does now there is this uh
once once that goes through then it's
like whatever they're drafting everybody
but until that point now they really
have a little bit of an issue on their
hands because we're told to buy
Administration in particular says that
even in the context of the military in
most other contexts they say that a male
who identifies as a woman
is a woman and should be treated that
way
always even even to the point of being
sent to a women's prison
you have a male sex offender a male
rapist should be sent to a women's
prison locked in a prison cell with
women
because he is a Woman They tell us
and yet
the only time when it's not going to
work the only government uh agency or
Department
the only the only organ of the
government that will not recognize your
female self-identity is selective
service are the people who would draft
you they're the only ones
so they're going to go along with it
we're going to pretend you're a woman in
every context including in context where
it's going to hurt other real women
um
especially in those contexts
but when we need you
know when the politicians need to send
you overseas
to die for one of their Wars
that's when the ACT is dropped
now we're not pretending anymore that
was all cute and fine not anymore
really uh tells you everything you need
to know
all right one other thing here what do
we got there's a couple to choose from
and we're running out of time in the
five headlines all right I want to
mention this because it's kind of
related this is uh from the daily wire
says author JK Rowling slammed the idea
that she's right wing simply because she
cares about child safeguarding and said
she's been on the liberal left all her
adult life rallying the famed Harry
Potter author who's been the target of
transgender activists because of her
defensive biological women I had several
comments on Twitter Friday explaining
that future historians will be able to
trace the path of the culture as it
relates to radical gender ideology she
says I say this as someone who's been on
the liberal left all her adult life own
goals don't come any more spectacular
than if you care about child
safeguarding you must be right wing
the crazy thing about this is it's all
been documented virtually minute by
minute future historians won't be
struggling to find out how this cultural
moment happened think how many books
blogs videos speeches and documentaries
will be available to them
so she is once again reasserting her
Bona fides as a leftist and we've seen
this from her before we know obviously
when she when she disavowed me a few
months ago
um and said yeah I thought what is a
woman was fine but you know not not this
guy I don't want to be on the same side
of this guy so this is not this is not
anything new for her I just wonder
and I and I and I once again as I've
said so many times I but I I do feel the
need to reiterate because it's true
that she's had a lot of Courage on this
issue
serves a lot of credit for that yes
she's a multi-billionaire yes she's has
enough money to retire for the next one
million lifetimes and so you might say
that she's got nothing to lose but
you do have something to lose
yeah when you got a lot of money like
when you're a billionaire you just kind
of take that for Billy okay yeah you're
rich you always will be and you just
like you take that for granted at a
certain point
um you don't think of that as something
that you can lose because you can't but
there are other things you can lose that
you still value and cherish and you
might cherish them even more now that
money is like not an issue anymore to
think about
um things like your reputation your uh
you know the admiration people have for
you in the mainstream
so those are things
that she had and she's now lost
um in the mainstream anyway
for someone like me it's gone the
opposite I have respect our help a lot
more than I did before but uh she
doesn't really care she's made it clear
she doesn't care what I think or what
you think
so she has lost the respect of people
that
uh whose opinion she otherwise cares
about
and that that's something that's a lot
that takes guts
so all that said I I do wish that at
some point JK Rowling and and um
everyone in her kind of Camp the what
they call call themselves gender
critical feminists they're derisively
called turfs by the other side
but I wish that they would all just stop
and think for a second
I mean you you still claim you're you're
filthy to the left and you say you've
been a liberal and you still believe all
of that
maybe stop and think about
okay why is it that your side has lost
its mind if you notice that it's only on
your side
you still claim this as your side
broadly in the ideological
struggle
and yet you are on the side that has
totally lost a script on grip on reality
maybe you should think about that and
you should think about whether you still
want to
align yourself with that
you should think about are there some
fundamental like is it just a
coincidence
that this gender ideology this trans
stuff came along on the left is that a
coincidence could it have been either
one it could have been the right you
know it could have been conservative too
but it just ended up in just some some
Quirk of History it just ended up being
leftists who got all behind gender
ideology and you know women have penises
and all the rest of it
is it that or is there something
fundamentally in leftism that inevitably
led to this because I think it's very
much the latter
and there's a lot there that we could
talk about we don't have time for but
I'll point to one thing the rejection of
objective truth okay leftism is
inherently a relativistic
worldview
always has been
and that's where all this stems from
ultimately there's a lot more that goes
into it
it's not the leftism is also anti-family
it's anti-anything that that that
that's a has the stench of tradition you
know in their in their minds anything
like that so they're anti-all of that
inherently destructive inherently
um anti-truth
that's where it comes from
let me think about that and say well you
know maybe I'm not a liberal maybe I'm
not on the liberal left or I shouldn't
be
something to think about as we get into
our comment section daily cancellations
of the day
[Music]
while this is a uh the segment of the
show dedicated to the SBG really every
segment of the show is dedicated to my
dear sweet babies but this in particular
um and because of that I need to make
sure to give special credit and issue
accommodations to
the SBG who showed up to an event on
Saturday in Michigan where I was
speaking
um a uh a great conference called the
body of Christ in the Public Square
event
conference and it's a wonderful event
run and attended by some very solid
Christians
but the SPG was there and to understand
why their presence was so especially
important and inspiring
just need a little bit of background
the background goes back to the greatest
controversy of this current century of
course which which I don't need to tell
you is Walter skate the controversy
which did not conclude and was not
settled when Ben Shapiro finally
released his grip on my life-sized
stuffed walrus that was only the end of
chapter one that was one struggle in the
beginning of another one because now
that it's been officially given to me in
theory anyway the next step is to bring
it home
but home is where my wife lives and she
has never been on board I'm afraid to
say with the giant stuffed walrus she
has never understood my pain over its
absence nor by desire for its presence
and that's why to this day
The Walrus still is not at my house it's
not there it's it's it's uh it's still
at work still in the studio
in fact my wife went around me she
usurped me
and started texting and calling people
at work to prevent them from bringing it
home this is true it's what she did
I was actually on the air one day and
she was conspiring
she and my assistant Tessa were in
particular reached some sort of
agreement
whereby now the walrus is is still at
the office it's not it's not in my house
um you have to understand that my wife
by the way has a direct line to everyone
I work with and will simply go around me
whenever it suits her but she has she
has the numbers of everybody in the
wardrobe department and she has no
problem calling them to give her opinion
about you know wardrobe issues she
obviously is in touch with um
with everybody
and and
somehow this agreement was was was
sorted out and so I don't have the
walrus now
um so anyway
my wife's argument against the walrus is
that number one she thinks we don't have
room for it in the house which is absurd
because if we lived in a damned
double-wide trailer I would still say we
have room for the walrus okay get rid of
the couch and put the walrus there you
can sit on it too by the way
and she says we can't fit it through the
door which okay you can take the door
off you can cut a hole in the side of
the house it's been done before
um you can it can bust through the wall
like the Kool-Aid man whatever you got
to do these are not real problems these
are excuses I'm a solution man I'm not
an excuses guy I don't want to hear the
excuses tell me the solutions and if you
don't have them I'll tell you what they
are cut a hole in the wall that's it
that's the solution
this brings us to the event this weekend
which my wife attended with me and she
was in the audience when someone came to
the microphone during the Q a addressed
me as Sweet Daddy Walsh which which my
creeped my wife out to no end so I was
so glad she was there for that and then
also asked about the walrus and it and
it gave me an opportunity
on the stage with the microphone
to make my case for bringing the walrus
home and I was able to to get the
audience to plot along with me so it was
like 400 Against One
and you have to understand it in a
marriage you know it's a man-woman
argument men are often at a disadvantage
uh but when you have the microphone and
she doesn't
that's a whole different ballgame it
made me think that I should just I
should have a stage and a microphone in
my house so that anytime we're arguing
about something I'll just get up on the
stage and I'll
you know
just start shouting it into the
microphone maybe I'll start live
streaming it too to get so the SVG can
see the argument and everyone will get
on my side
anyway the Waller still isn't home even
after all that Jack straw says uh I
drove 49 miles last night to hear sweet
Daddy's lecture I got detoured by road
construction on campus and by the time I
found parking it was 7 55 and couldn't
get in there I stood ticket in hand and
unable to hear Matt Walsh speak this is
at the college event by the way not the
uh the other thing I tried to bargain
with the person at the door to no avail
so I sat outside the hall and watched it
on YouTube it was a long trip it was it
was not for naught because I was able to
trigger a protester by misgendering it
I'm glad to hear that part and I hate
that you couldn't make it in though Jack
you know Taiwan we'll uh we'll send you
we'll get in touch with you we'll send
you a signed t-shirt
and a signed book
and a stuffed walrus
and a couple stickers
and
they left his tears mug signed
and I've just promised all those things
so we have to do it now otherwise I'd be
a liar
a reed says the Optics of these events
are always exactly what you'd expect
massive crowds of normal looking
well-behaved people versus small groups
of colorful crybabies and social
parasites
those are those aren't any Optics and so
you can watch and just decide whose side
you're on it's really up to you
um
gray Webb says if your presence makes
her feel unsafe why is she in the same
building you're in
yeah that is that is really the ultimate
question
and as we were talking about the
protesters and how they felt unsafe and
they were complaining and all that
well if you're really that unsafe what
why are you you could leave the building
you don't have to I'm not forcing you to
be in the building I didn't I didn't
show up to the building that you were in
I didn't like show up I didn't chase you
down I wasn't chasing you across the
campus so if you're really if you really
feel unsafe
then you would then just go somewhere
else
but that's an easy solution and that's
exactly what they don't they want the
excuse they want the excuse to complain
they don't actually want
uh the solution
happy Columbus Day folks 530 years ago
Columbus uh discovered the new world but
the left ruined it so Jeremy is building
a new new world starting with his razors
and right now you can get your Jeremy's
razors founder shave kit for 40 off plus
free shipping as part of a historic
Columbus Day Sale the left wants to
erase history and masculinity but you
don't have to let them navigate your way
to jeremy'srazers.com to conquer your
stubble and arrive and style this
holiday now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we go
back a few months to a video posted in
June which is reacting to my film what
is a woman um I wasn't aware this video
existed until someone happened to send
it to me last week and
um we'll take a look at it we'll talk
about it now because
it helps me illustrate a point that I
want to make and that's you know that's
when you that's a good way to get into
the cancellation is if you say something
that that just plays into an overall
overarching point I I Feel Like Making
and uh that's what's happening here and
the guy in this clip is someone named
Jordan B Cooper who's a theologian and
author president of the American
Lutheran Theological Seminary I also
hosts a podcast I believe based on what
very little I know about the guy I'm
assuming the two of us probably agree on
a great many important issues in fact we
agree about the issue that lies at the
center of the film so we're up really on
the same page in so many ways and Cooper
seems to appreciate the film and has
some nice things to say about the
content and about the approach that we
took and yet you can't get fully behind
it because as he sees it
my documentary has one fatal flaw I'm
involved
let's listen
so I think there there are some things I
want to say about about the film The the
first of those is honestly I think the
film would have been more effective if
it was not put out by the daily wire and
particularly Matt Walsh and and I don't
mean this
I don't mean that as an insult to him or
them as an organization anyway
whatsoever they they are a they're a
political group so they do political
things and he's a political figure and
this has you know very very much has
political implications but the reason I
say that is because the these issues of
gender
really extend far beyond the
conservative quote unquote conservative
liberal divider Republican Democrat
Divine of course these things affect
people from all over the world it's not
just our American political context that
determines uh everything even though us
Americans tend to think everything
centers around us but it doesn't
these are much broader philosophical
claims that are being made surrounding
gender that don't have really anything
to do with politics
there are assertions about what a male
is and what a female is and questions
maybe more than assertions because there
are no real answers that are dependent
upon particular philosophical constructs
that have not in any way been proven but
are instead being forced upon people
foreign
movie which Matt Walsh made would be a
lot better without Matt Walsh in it
there are some major logical problems
with such a criticism of course like if
I made a painting and you said that you
really liked the painting
um it wouldn't make any sense to then
add that the painting would have been
better if I hadn't been the one to paint
it
now it may be true that other people
could make better paintings but this
specific painting wouldn't exist at all
without me so if I wasn't involved in
the making of the painting you wouldn't
have a better version of the painting
you just you just wouldn't have this
painting in the first place it wouldn't
exist
as we'll pick up on that thought in just
a moment but here's a little bit more of
Jordan Cooper
but I think because of the nature of the
fact that it is Matt Walsh making the
documentary that it will turn a lot of
people off from it and make and I think
give the impression that this is just
another kind of Republican Democrats
issue and and it's really not and you
see that especially even through the
people interviewed throughout and people
that are speaking up on these issues
that this this absolutely 100 should not
be a Democrat Republican issue
this is a question of who is the human
person
what determines what and who you are is
it what you say you are is is truth
determined just by whatever
the linguistic concept Society happens
to use even if it can't Define it or is
there something real about what we
encounter in our everyday experiences
what what philosophically would be
referred to as realism or essentialism
that I know is a bad word among uh
gender theorists but unfortunately I do
think that the fact that Matt Walsh is
involved is going to make a bunch of
people kind of turn it off and say it's
just some political thing
[Music]
well I'm sorry for being involved in my
own project I should have known better
though his critique about the alleged
political nature of the film makes it
sound like we spend the whole runtime
ranting against Democrats and Shilling
for republicans and there is in fact
none of that in the movie we do
interview and ultimately embarrass a
Democrat politician but his humiliation
is entirely self-induced
so what is Cooper's actual criticism he
tries to sort of make it about the
approach of the film itself but but
ultimately it's clear that he likes the
approach he doesn't like or at least
doesn't terribly respect uh at least in
this case me or the daily wire now he's
far from the only Christian in a
position of leadership who's voiced this
kind of objection to not only what is a
woman but all of the other work that
we're doing on the gender ideology issue
and in the culture in general
so they they so I hear this kind of
thing a lot they appreciate the work
but they really wish we weren't the ones
doing it because they're so deeply
uncomfortable with us and about various
different things about us
uh they wish that we could leave it to
more credible Christian voices to you
know handle these kinds of things
those who can make more robust
theological arguments those who have
phds and moral theology
the problem with me they say is that uh
I'm too polarizing I'm too abrasive I'm
too controversial and what's more I'm
not educated enough not eloquent enough
not uh not the right kind of Christian
not the right sort of voice
and to those criticisms I say yes
uh basically true I am too much of some
things and not enough of others I am a
very flawed vessel
so why did I make the film
well because
no one else did
why am I fighting at the front lines in
this battle well because there aren't
very many other people scrambling to get
up here
there especially aren't aren't very many
Christian leaders coming to the front
it's not as though the Foxhole is full
okay if you came up we're not going to
say oh we don't have room for you we got
too many people who want to be here no
no we got plenty of room down in the
trenches
we invite any educated PhD wielding
Christian Pastor or Theologian who wants
to jump down into the mud with with us
and get their hands dirty we invite you
all to come
there's a few here already with us but
not that many
instead they seem to prefer to stay far
back from where most of the real
fighting is going on lobbying grenades
that ultimately end up hitting us rather
than the enemy
now the daily wire we encounter this
sort of thing pretty frequently
this is why it's maybe just really
annoys me at this point
one other quick example we released the
Jeremy's razors commercial back in March
of this year and we did something that
no other conservative organization has
done to my knowledge which is a high
price sponsor left us because it opposed
our values and rather than changing our
values to keep the sponsor we told the
sponsor to go to hell and we made a
product to directly compete with them
instead
big win it's an important cultural
counter punch
but some Christians were uncomfortable
with it it's uncomfortable Toby Sumpter
is a prominent Pastor co-host of a
popular podcast called cross politic I
do a lot of good things on on the
podcast I've listened to it
but he wrote a lengthy article attacking
the Jeremy's razors ad claiming absurdly
that we somehow had sold out by making
it and he explained all the ways that it
could have been done better he also
threw an irrelevant Blindside punch at
me and Michael Knowles accusing us of
being papist idolaters
you see the whole lot of Jeremy's
Razor's campaign is a nice idea he says
but but he knows how it could have been
done better
he could have done it better
and yet
he isn't doing it better
and never has has he ever produced
anything with the cultural relevance of
what the daily wire creates has he ever
had a real substantive win in the
culture in the way that we have
that we're changing laws and saving kids
from getting mutilated and making
content that has a real lasting
noticeable impact for the good in our
culture is Toby Sumpter doing that is
Jordan B Cooper
by the way I won't surprise you to learn
that the cross politic guys also
criticized what is a woman on the
grounds that I'm Catholic which means
the film in terms of impact quote won't
do much and B um I didn't bring Jesus
into the film in the scene where I'm
debating the pro-trans pediatrician they
wanted me to launch into a sermon about
the saving power of Jesus Christ in the
middle of the movie and because I didn't
you know that's a that's a big problem
once again they've they could have made
a much better version of the movie a
much more Christian you know much more
Christian much Holier version
and yet they haven't
they didn't
they aren't
see Christian leaders those who actually
Pastor churches and have degrees in
Theology and so on
they've spent the last several decades
suffering one defeat after another in an
unrelenting and unbroken chain of
failure
our culture has slipped ever further
into madness into moral confusion and
abject insanity and all while they
preside in their positions of alleged
leadership
doing nothing I mean so so look there
there are two kinds of culturally
ineffectual Christian leaders in the
country
the first and I would say the more
common brand
are those pastors and other people in
positions of spiritual leadership who
have simply surrendered the moral fight
outright right they run from
any issue that might be considered
controversial they choose instead to
drone on about the faux virtues of
Tolerance and inclusivity some of them
haven't just fled from the controversial
fights but instead have actually adopted
the mainstream positions
in those arguments Now using their
undeserved credibility to directly shill
for gender ideology abortion the
destruction of marriage and the family
and so on
this is uh one category
but and certainly the more pathetic and
shameful one to be sure
but it's not the one I'm concerned with
today because there's this other
category that doesn't get criticized
quite as much
the other type of ineffectual Christian
leader
is the type who maintains his belief in
and defense of Christian values
rejects the spirit of the age adopts the
correct positions
talks about important things
but only talks about them
he's very impressed with his theological
and philosophical training and wants us
to be impressed too he pontificates in
the abstract saying many intelligent
things and impressing everyone uh who
already agrees with him anyway and who
shares his level of education and
erudition
this type not only makes no real inroads
in the culture not only fails to win any
battles but indeed prefers not to win
them
because he likes being on the losing
side this is his brand it's his Mo and
it's his cover
because the culture is lost anyway he
reasons there's no point in putting up a
fight
he can't win none of us can he says
which means that nobody can judge him
for not winning
which means that uh there's no way to
discern whether he is achieving anything
at all in his career so there's really
no pressure we can't accuse him of
losing because we're all losing all the
time and that's how he likes it
this is why someone who belongs to this
category actually actively opposes any
attempt by conservatives to make
progress in the culture
the only reason to engage with the
culture at all they think is to Virtue
signal to it
doesn't want to change the culture he
just wants the culture to know how
different he is from it
now not every Pastor priest Christian
leader in the country falls into one of
these categories
but most do
and if they didn't we wouldn't be in the
position that we're in
this used to be a Christian Society
it is no longer
and hasn't been for a long time it slid
all the way down the slippery slope and
off into the abyss While most of the
people tasked with preventing such a
decline were at the wheel too afraid or
too distracted by the sounds of their
own voices to bother steering us away
from destruction
so now the job Falls to other people
I mean it falls to people who may be a
little bit edgier than you'd like a
little rough around the edges a little
problematic
not the right kind of Christians
not Christian at all in some cases
this uh Rogues Gallery this collection
of Misfits will be out there in the
fight
doing what needs to be done
and what you never did
and refuse to do even now
and you can stand back safe and out of
range criticizing and pontificating and
tell us telling us what a better job you
would be doing if you were doing
anything at all
you can make yourself feel better that
way
while the battle is fought and
ultimately won by others
and that's why because this is the
segment we're doing you are today
canceled
that'll do it for uh today we'll talk to
you tomorrow
have a great day Godspeed
[Music]
hey there this is John Bickley daily
wire editor-in-chief and co-host of
morning wire on today's episode the U.S
labor market slows Vanderbilt University
pauses its gender surgeries for children
and will New York elect a republican
Governor join us and get the facts first
on the news you need to know with our
show morning wire
[Music]